visualizations are more than just data
or charts or maps
at their best they're a story humans
really have been telling each other
stories as their primary means of
communications and education for tens of
thousands of years
whether around a campfire or using
modern media the fact of the matter is
that there's a lot of power to the
phrase once upon a time
we're wired for stories and
visualization takes work to create
stories out of it
and some of that work really has nothing
to do with the visualization
it really is about the storytelling
aspect to it
just like great design is about strategy
and thinking and planning before the
first stroke of the paintbrush
it's no less so in visualization
visualizations
especially interactive ones aren't
necessarily consumed in a linear way
like a book you can't necessarily
control how your user processes the
information you give them
but you can structure a story in a
narrative way with a narrative process
you could encourage users to walk
through the information in a linear
progressive way even though you can't
force them to do it
so let's look at stories the fact is
that stories have a very simple
structure everyone has a beginning a
middle and an end
a more nuanced view includes a few more
elements
the beginning of the story and then the
protagonist faces a serious challenge
and then there's the middle of the story
and then there's some sort of climax
then there's the de numa that's sort of
like after the climax
things start to wrap up all the way down
into the grand finale where the book
closes
if you think about your visualization in
these terms as much as you can
you really can't go wrong here we're
going to design a visualization together
using this structure as our guiding
principle
so the first thing you do is you define
a headline and there may be more than
one headline
in fact it is recommended that you go
through the process of thinking of more
than one
it is as if coming up with a new york
times headline which is a very serious
and journalistic
and straightforward headline and then
there's the new
york post version which is a little bit
more salacious and crazy and scandal
written
sort of the fun one versus the serious
one
and sometimes for your visualizations
you may lean one way or the other but
play around with headlines
the headline is the most important top
line summation of the story you're
trying to tell
you can also think about the headline in
terms of what will people tweet when
they share your visualization
and you also want to when you're coming
up with your headline
actually use blank spaces when you're
thinking about it for the data parts
so in other words you want to minimize
bias
your next point in the hierarchy of your
data visualization
is your introduction in an infographic
like this
it's just a paragraph it's establishing
the premise and the context for the
visualization before diving into the
data
and it belongs below the headline at the
top of the page to draw the either first
again this is conceptual and structural
using the story as our guiding principle
this is not meant to be the design if
you think of it in the story standpoint
the headline
and the introduction is the beginning of
our story
now let's move on to the challenge there
are a lot of ways to add the challenge
to a visualization
one is simply to add a call out big
bolded text like this that calls out the
main idea of the story you're trying to
tell or
the problem that's being addressed or
the question that your visualization is
meant to answer
in this wireframe this bold type will
really draw the eye
in a real graphic it could take
different visual forms
we've set up the premise we've gotten
the user into it now we're going to load
them up with data
and here's where the chart with all the
detail and the interactivity and imagery
is going to go
in this gray area in the middle this is
where the user is going to spend most of
their time really exploring and playing
around and looking at the data
next how do we introduce the climax the
sort of pivotal moment in the experience
and we're going to look at two different
scenarios one is a static infographic
and one is an interactive chart
in a static infographic you have
information here
that's really meant to be consumed
linearly
of course people are going to start on
the left if they're left to right
language readers
they're going to follow the arrows and
more likely than not
end up on the right hand side but if we
had a climax
a big story a special thing that we
wanted to draw attention to
we're going to highlight it maybe in a
visually interesting way
so we're going to create a focal point
that's going to contain the climax
it could actually contain the conclusion
or the challenge
this might draw the either first of
course we might have killed that linear
progression experience because someone
is going to read this first
but again the idea isn't necessarily to
enforce linear consumption of the
content
it's just to use that structure when
you're thinking about it
now if we are trying to do this in an
interactive graphic
the approach might be a little bit
different you can enforce a linear
consumption of the content by having a
next button and making your users click
next
and next to reveal one piece of the
story after another exactly how you want
to tell it
and then you can do the big reveal at
the end of that process
so now we have the exact same visual
structure as the static infographic
but we're forcing the user to get to it
piece by piece bit by bit
or another way to do it is to have
sorting and filtering buttons
you might put your filters in a certain
order and again
assuming people are going to go left to
right which is a relatively safe
assumption
but not always you can encourage a user
to use certain filters first
clicking on the left and then when they
click on that filter
you might be able to highlight certain
things when the data reveals
one bar is taller than the others and
you can use a callout to highlight
something interesting that happened
there
again the user is progressing through
the content and there isn't necessarily
a de numa
sometimes you might not get the
opportunity to conclude things for them
because they couldn't find the things
they are looking for and just leave
it's hard in that situation to offer
conclusions and to deconstruct things
for them sometimes
but it's a really good exercise to try
to think about how you would do that
if we go back to our static infographic
it's really easy to offer a conclusion
on the page
we're used to seeing it in the lower
right hand corner
you have a box with the small print the
footer
it's very easy to see structurally it is
also strongly recommended that you
always include your sources
where did this data come from why should
one believe you
why is it valid it is part of the
conclusion in a story structure
in an interactive infographic you can
also offer more conclusion like things
after your users go through this deep
exploration process
they're trying to find deeper
information and their own discovery
they can deconstruct the info themselves
but then at the end
there's a next button and they click
through and you can sort of offer them
this summed up view of the data
there are a lot of ways to introduce
conclusions in denumas into
interactivity
even though you're never guaranteed that
people will experience them
it's really helpful to think of every
project even your non-linear interactive
ones within that linear storytelling
framework
it helps you work through functionality
logic as well as the hierarchy of
information
and it also helps you measure your
success